welcome back to new rock stars i'm
whitney van laningham and honestly you
guys i think ms marvel might be a better
youtuber than me true sloth baby
productions only has like two followers
at the beginning of the show but i would
watch the heck out of her 10-part
avenger series and kamala isn't the only
one with video centric social media in
the mcu we've seen several other
instances of heroes and civilians
youtube and streaming accounts so today
i'm going to break down all of them who
they follow what they post and even who
else in universe they might be
subscribed to let's start with peter
parker whose youtube channel we first
heard mention back in civil war peter
parker being captured on film obviously
isn't a new concept with parker
capturing his own shots the daily bugle
throughout the comics and the sony verse
we know this character has always had an
eye for self-made content creation even
though spidey working as a photographer
is an absolute classic it definitely
makes sense to upload his action in
video form seeing a guy hang upside down
is very cool but seeing a guy stop a 3
000 car from becoming yet another marvel
bus tragedy is way cooler seriously
though what does the mcu have against
public transportation leave those poor
vehicles alone they didn't do anything
to you if you recall tony stark showed
up in aunt may's living room looking for
peter confronting him with a video of
spider-man stopping a thief breaking
into a car followed by footage of him
stopping a car from t-boning a city bus
if you look closely at the video that
tony shows peter it's marked active
camera footage but peter attempts to
cover for himself by saying you found
that on youtube right the youtube
channel that uploads these videos is
called rocketrobinson67
likely a play on robbie robertson who
debuted in 1967's the amazing spider-man
this channel used to exist in real life
and was used as a supplementary easter
egg slash marketing tool but the videos
have since been taken down eric pointed
out in one of his past videos that the
top comment on the video is from a user
called tubins54 and reads fake and it
might be peter parker's personal youtube
account at this point spidey still is
hell-bent on keeping his identity a
secret and for a very good reason he
likely wouldn't want any of his footage
to live forever on the internet and i
can see him doing anything he could to
dissuade rocket robinson 67 from
perpetuating the knowledge of his skills
and existence this account may also be
how tony stark found peter parker in the
first place when they first meet peter
tells him that the youtube video he saw
was fake until tony whipped out his own
projection of the incident as soon as
peter said that i bet that stark knew
for sure that he'd caught him
rocketrobinson67
is subscribed to waverly films channel
aka director john watts filmmaking group
made up of other folks in the biz who he
met at nyu film school these guys do
sketch comedy and cartoons on their
channel allen tutorial the channel whose
video is auto-playing next is run by
alan resnick who plays a fictionalized
version of himself as a dude who films
bizarre how-to videos then there's that
one video from a bmx channel so clearly
rocket robinson's interests are sick as
hell however due to the fact that we've
seen kamala's two subscribers comments
bruno's and nikias i don't think that he
follows her back yet he hasn't laid eyes
on those sweet sweet thumbnails yet if i
had to guess i'd say that flash thompson
wasn't initially subscribed but
definitely subbed as soon as he found
out that he could capitalize on all
those live streams even though these
videos of peter would have billions of
views in the real world in the mcu it
only has a few thousand obviously a few
thousand ain't nothing to sniff at it's
the quality of the video not the
quantity of use in my opinion but this
tells me that rocket robinson 67 doesn't
have as many followers as a larger
channel but perhaps that changed once
flashpoint was published i'm sure that
if flash did see those videos he'd tell
everyone about them flash's live stream
itself is likely on instagram snapchat
or something else in that multiverse
judging by the vertical selfie view we
see in the deleted scenes from far from
home hilariously flash only filmed
himself during all of those badass fight
scenes so you can't even really see
peter mysterio or any of the fake
elementals as for who follows flash
outside of his classmates at midtown
high i like to think that maybe kate
bishop kamala khan and the other gen z
heroes and hero fans also subscribe but
in my opinion kamala is definitely the
more likely one out of those two she's
definitely glued to ant-man's podcast
and has probably seen all of the
in-universe documentaries dramatizations
and other media surrounding the avengers
why wouldn't she be following someone
who started live streaming about
superhero battles on a class trip to
italy i also have a headcanon that she
totally bought carol a definitive
account of the cosmic avenger before
things went sideways at avengercon and
you bet your sweet boots that kate
bishop picked up a copy of i was there
because it boasts an interview with her
bestie hawkeye kamala khan's youtube
numbers at sloth baby productions might
be low in episode one but like i said up
top i think she'd have thousands of
followers in real life seriously the
animation youtube community would
absolutely eat up those adorable
thumbnails she'd be getting commissions
like every day honestly i would also
kill to see her animated take on the
what was he cooking thumbnail because
she would crush it and the stop motion
she does with those cardboard cutouts
and painted backgrounds are incredible
not to mention her editing is top-notch
and so is her hosting that performance
voice is dynamic baby girl would have me
out of a job if i was in the mcu so
thank god i live in another dimension
because i gotta work to feed pugsley
somehow and pizza pogo always gets paid
i seriously can't believe that she only
has two subscribers and that they're
both her two best friends not that
they're excellent taste doesn't count
but she deserves more views damn it she
has a consistent upload schedule and
clearly puts hours of effort into her
videos but we do have an idea of what
kinds of channels she follows ones like
ours while i sincerely hope that kamala
is a huge fan of my variant on the mcu's
new rockstars i bet she subscribes to
every single avengers related media that
she can get her hands on big me little
me can't be the only podcast she's a
super fan of i think that any of our
favorite shows in the real world are
fair game to have a variant in the mcu
and i bet that ms marvel has pretty much
the same taste as all of us do sully
clearly has a lot more followers and is
apparently sitting at 100k although we
haven't seen any of her media directly
it's clear that almost everyone at her
high school and a lot of others are
following her flash would definitely be
following her because even though they
live like a whole state away it seems
like her reach stretches farther than
just new jersey with those numbers she's
an influencer so any number of super and
regular folks could be following her
next we have thor who definitely plays
fortnite i know that yelling at someone
on playstation isn't technically under
the category of youtube or social media
but i'm sure he at least has a twitch
account to watch live streams and
playthroughs with korg we also found out
via an xbox commercial featuring falcon
that thor's nemesis noobmaster69 is none
other than aaron the apple store
employee from the winter soldier he says
his cousin made up his gamertag but we
all know it was him my theory is that
after meeting cap and black widow in the
flesh he probably also started following
every marvel live stream that he could
get his hands on i'm not sure if thor
himself knows how to work instagram but
noob master 69 probably follows flash
thompson at the very least lastly we
gotta talk about klev the streamer on
the bus in shanghai he probably got the
idea to start after he successfully
convinced spider-man to do a flip for
him 10 bucks says that ms marvel
subscribed immediately after she saw
this footage and flash probably did too
some of the subscribers on the side of
his live stream include the tessa bear
koala kana the real joe of oz cassiopeia
lawyer dad digital lotus penguin sita
pineapple pen double 07 oops wrong sight
vic 3205 johnny aces sunset glitterberry
power of crab auntie darkness fast car
30303 simon guy 3000 mohawk koala and
beep boop in his shang chi breakdown
eric theorized that climbing guy 3000
could be peter parker due to his
climbing abilities and tony stark's
daughter morgan loving him 3000. he also
thought that agatha harkness could be
anti-darkness due to how similar that
sounds to her name and the purple
background of the text i'm also
wondering now that we've seen ms marvel
if koala kana is kamala khan because we
know that she loves cute lazy little
animals and it also sounds so similar to
her real name also you cannot tell me
that fast car 30303 isn't the mcu's
variant of dominic toretto because you
would absolutely be lying and i won't
tolerate or debate this i think that
kamala definitely follows cleve whether
or not that's her stream or screen name
but peter likely hasn't set up any new
account since his identity was erased
hopefully we'll get to see more of
kamala's adorable videos in future
episodes because i am definitely a huge
fan follow me on instagram and twitter
whitneypuppy follow new rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you